okay this is a candy crush soda saga
level 20 walkthrough tutorial video had
a couple of players who were having
trouble with this level in our group so
I'm gonna make this video and play
through it and discuss the tips as we go
so and as you can see when you first
start out you have to get four bears
this number could change based on the
size but there's no candy pieces on this
side also what we want to do first of
all is get rid of these blockers so that
we can get candies to go up that way and
I'm gonna make special as well I do that
because they'll slide right through
all right so now we can look at me and
see where some of the bears are we see
we have two in here and we have one of
them right there so you can't really
just attack the Bears you want to what
you want to do is you want to make some
really big combos that'll clear out lots
of lots of place at the same time and so
like this color color bomb plus the fish
would be great so I'm just looking over
here to see if there's a place where I
can drop it
we're a little farther than I wanted to
but at least now we can see where all
the bears are so what we'll do is well
you know we'll make matches that make
specials that will hit the Bears like
hit the ice above the Bears and then
look like I said to see if we can't make
a big combo out of this one then we can
right here we can drop this strike right
next to it so that'll be great to clear
out ice
okay so we got 18 moves and we have one
two three four or five pieces ice that
we have to play out and I'm right here
you can see we could set up another big
one I can make a color bomb and then I
can match it match these Reds and get it
together with that striped candy so
that's what I'm gonna do
and you can see also one thing that
helps is making matches on this side
creates a cascade on this side so you
can you can pick up you know extra
pieces with the ice just through the
Cascade and this should give us really
close to finishing you could this is a
this is gonna breathe this bears a
muscle go ahead and do that first since
we have 15 rows up and then we make our
big man big combo
and that gets all but one
so
we make this yellow maxi that's gonna
drop these four orange ones and three of
them down and then we can finish this by
making their last wish
so it's not that bad if you plan ahead
and you think about you know obviously
you want to get that those blockers out
of the way first and then you want to
remember that if you make matches up
here that it's gonna bring cascades down
that are gonna take out candy for you
and you really need to make a color bomb
or coloring candy with a stripe or a
fish to really get through all the ice
quickly hope you found this helpful
please like the video and subscribe to
our Channel Thanks